. Let me go next to let's go to Adam from
Irvine, California.
Adam from Irvine.
What's going on?
Adam from Irvine, California, can hear background
noise, you were on the air.
Well, this year, just barely.
It's got to be better, marginally, are you
running a buzz saw in the background?
No serious question, but I want to know what
you.
I met with military advisers.
So how are you?
Are you using an electric shaver right now?
I was the question about Trump firing military
advisers.
Yes.
Oh, OK.
Listen, I'm going to take it off air because
it's it's that's wild.
Listen, so Trump firing military advisors,
there's kind of two questions.
One, if he's out in nine weeks, why is he
firing anybody?
What difference does it make that?
So that's that's sort of like one question.
The other side of it is, is this part of a
planned military coup?
I think this is just Trump's a petulant child
and he's firing people who he's been at odds
with.
And he would have fired them months ago were
it not for somebody saying, hey, you know
what, you might want to wait until after the
election perfectly.
To be perfectly honest, I think it's that
simple.
I don't think we should read much more into
it.
And, you know, there's people acting like
Trump's a criminal genius here, staging some
coup by replacing Mark Esper